let's go next to our caller from the
3:03 area code caller from 3:03
who maybe is making tea or whistling in
the background yes are we on speaker or
Bluetooth very good hello hello yes
that's much better
hey I had a question man so yeah I have
a question so I'm leaning a little more
I'm in the middle of either a democratic
or a Republican I had a question because
I'm not too sure like I see usually like
CNN usually talks bad about Trump I just
want to know what do you if any do you
have any policies that you necessarily
agree that he's put in place or anything
that you uh character that yeah that
Trump has put in yeah I mean listen so
one of the things that I think overall
Trump's tax plan was a disaster but one
of the things he did is he lowered the
threshold at which point medical
expenses become deductible I think that
that's good you know I think that that I
mean it's like it's it's very it's it's
pennies on the dollar it's a drop in the
bucket but I think that was the right
decision
he made a couple tiny little tweaks
around disclosure of pharmaceutical
pricing that I think are fine but that
you know they don't really change the
broader problems we have like yeah I can
find little tiny things if you you know
kind of push my hand sure oh I was
curious because I don't know I like I
said I've I've been always in the middle
like I don't necessarily agree with all
these gun right that I think liberals
are more pushing or censorship kind of
deal but I do agree with some things
like health care but I just I kind of
find myself in the middle and I'm having
a hard time with this I mean let's cut
remind me what your name was I don't
know if I caught it oh sorry it's
Mackenzie Mackenzie okay Mackenzie
listen all right when you look around do
you think right now that we have an
imbalance of power in this country where
the rich have too much power or do you
think that they don't I think they do
in most places yeah okay and when you
look around do you think that huge
businesses are over regulated and can't
make any money or do you think that
businesses are getting away with things
like paying no taxes while raping and
pillaging the environment
well that's why I may disagree I do
agree that they may be getting away with
some taxes but if you look into like
business models and development or I
guess ideas that they put money and
invest in I think that that's something
that not a lot of people look at like I
don't know if you point out Amazon and
say oh they have been taxed a lot or it
should be taxed more but you look at how
we are getting two days shipping one day
shipping something that 10 years ago you
would have thought was oh that's
impossible I wouldn't be able to get
that object we're doing it when it comes
to that if I were to tell you the way
Amazon is able to do that and do it
cheaply is by subcontracting those
one-day delivery deliveries to under
licensed and untrained third party
delivery companies that are getting into
accidents that are you know getting into
all sorts of trouble and then Amazon
says hey it's not our problem they're
not our employees that's it does that
sound okay to you or does that sound
like a problem definitely does sound
like a problem I'm not to educate them
s-so got it they have it and when you
look around the world McKenzie and you
see people like Rodrigo Duterte
and Kim jong-un and Vladimir Putin and
Bashar al-assad and whoever else
are those the types of leaders that you
want our president to be more like or
less like big picture for me definitely
less like because I wouldn't like you
know the bad things that they do over
there
so listen everything I've asked you so
far means that if you vote your values
you could not possibly vote for Donald
Trump in 2020 now which of the
Democratic candidates we could talk
about but I don't see anything in there
that would at any sensible way mean Oh
Trump is the person that you would you
would be voting for I just don't see any
points of agreement yeah I definitely do
agree there but I'm personally I was a
Bernie supporter I definitely liked the
three college idea I mean I don't
personally go to college okay but I do
agree that like investing in the younger
class will definitely help the future
but part of me is is more on the fiscal
side if I see where that money is going
necessarily come from which which we can
have but listen I'm glad we did this
because to me and I think the audience
will agree and check out the YouTube
comments when we upload this you're
clearly someone who should be voting for
one of the Democratic candidates and
which one kind of remains to be
determined well thank you for your time
David be calling a lot more my first
time calling you thank you sir all right
very good appreciate the phone call I
apologize that I am out of time but I am
sorry to everybody I didn't get to I see
Ronald Reagan is holding and Colin
earlier next time Ronald and I will
definitely get to you